We've reached the end of lesson one, and we've covered a lot of concepts
that can be summarized into four main
points. Point one. Every human is a collection
of traits. Traits that can be described
as either physical or behavioral, visible or hidden,
and learned or innate. Point two. Inheritance
patterns have been described in many different ways.
[INAUDIBLE]
Two important ways are blended versus particulate
inheritance. With particulate inheritance laying the foundation for
modern genetics, and our idea of the individual
unit called a gene. Point three. The Environment
can play a major role in the presentation of certain traits. And point four. The
hereditary material that's passed down from generation to
generation is made up of a chemical substance
called DNA which comprises what we call our genome.